la séance est ouverte
en application de l'article 28 de la
Constitution la session ordinaire 2022
2023 est ouverte le compte-rendu
intégral de la séance du jeudi 4 août a
été publié sur le site internet du Sénat
y a-t-il des observations non le
procès-verbal est adopté
j'ai le regret de vous faire part du
décès de nos anciens collègues Louis
griot qui fut sénateur de la Côte d'Or
de 1998 à 2008 Michel doublet qui fut
sénateur de la Charente-Maritime de 1989
à 2014
Jacques Mayas qui fut sénateur de la
Seine-Saint-Denis de 1995 à 2011
j'informe le Sénat que conformément à
l'article 8 de notre règlement le 11
septembre dernier Monsieur Jean-Marie
Janssen est devenu membre de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
Daphné rachmadou est devenu membre de la
commission des affaires économiques
mes chers collègues la Conférence des
Présidents a inscrit le prochain débat
d'actualité à l'ordre du jour du
mercredi 5 octobre à 16h30 après
concertation avec les groupes politiques
se débat porterait sur proposition de
Monsieur le Président du Sénat sur le
thème suivant
atteinte au droit des femmes et aux
droits de l'homme en Iran sous forme de
discussion générale
y a-t-il des observations
il en est ainsi décidé
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Sueur pour un rappel au règlement
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente en 2017 Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron président de la République
a déclaré
que lorsqu'un ministre était mis en
examen et lui paraissait qu'il devait
quitter le gouvernement d'ailleurs
un président
un précédent garde des Sceaux a été
amené à quitter le gouvernement je
constate par ailleurs que les avocats du
présent gardent des sceaux tiennent des
propos mettant lourdement en cause les
plus hautes autorités de la magistrature
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
monsieur le procureur général près la
Cour de cassation
dans ces conditions on peut se demander
comment le dit garde des sceaux peut
être garant de l'indépendance de la
justice enfin
je constate mes chers collègues
qu'il est tout à fait possible dans
l'état actuel des choses
que monsieur le garde des sceaux soit
conduit à contribuer à la désignation
du prochain procureur général près la
Cour de cassation qui sera ou qui serait
son accusateur
dans ces conditions j'en viens au rappel
au règlement monsieur carucci
j'ai l'honneur madame la Présidente
de vous demander au nom du groupe
socialiste
de vous demander de bien vouloir saisir
de ces questions monsieur le Président
du Sénat et de lui demander de demander
à madame la Première ministre de venir
devant le Sénat pour s'exprimer sur la
position du gouvernement sur les faits
que je viens de citer et sur les
conditions dans lesquelles danser dans
cette situation sera garantie
l'indépendance de la justice je vous
remercie merci
accéder de votre rappel aux règlements
et votre demande sera bien entendu
transmise à monsieur le Président du
Sénat
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
étagers généraux de la justice
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
Monsieur François Noël buffet pour le
groupe les républicains et pour 8
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues je suis
heureux de ce débat au Sénat inscrit à
l'initiative du groupe les républicains
sur les suites du rapport du Comité des
états généraux de la justice qui a été
remis au Président de la République le 8
juillet dernier je vous montre quelques
instants pour quitter l'estrade sur
laquelle je suis parce que j'ai une
impression de hauteur un peu étonnante
voilà c'est mieux comme ça merci de
votre patience il est le fruit d'un
travail approfondie auquel d'ailleurs
j'ai eu l'honneur de participer entre le
mois d'octobre 2021 et le mois d'avril
dernier
il faut rappeler que ces états généraux
de la Justice ont été initiés par le
Président de la République suite au cri
d'alarme je crois que l'on peut employer
ces mots assez fort d'une part de Madame
Chantal larince à leur première
présidente de la Cour de cassation et de
Monsieur François Molin se procure en
général près de cette même cour sur la
situation critique de la justice
française
puis de 7000 magistrats ont ensuite
signé une tribune dans la presse en
réaction au suicide dramatique de l'une
des leurs une de leurs collègues
dénonçant leurs conditions de travail et
la perte de sens de leur métier ce qui
est naturellement sans précédent le
malaise dans la justice est une réalité
on ne peut pas le contester la perte de
confiance des citoyens dans son action
aussi comme la montrer l'Agora de la
justice organisée par le Sénat le 27
septembre 2021
en 2019 la justice peut de mal au milieu
du gué conduite en commun avec la
commission des affaires sociales et dont
Agnès canailler Nathalie Delattre et
Pascal Gruny même la présidente furent
les rapporteurs et en 2021 le droit des
entreprises en difficulté à l'épreuve de
la crise dont François bonhomme est
animée fut rapporteur nos rapports
budgétaires également suivent
attentivement chaque année la situation
de la justice et ont souvent alerté sur
ces difficultés concrètes il est donc
heureux de retrouver de nombreux points
de convergence parmi les constats et
propositions du rapport des États
généraux avec les travaux du Sénat je
pense par exemple la mise en place d'un
tribunal des affaires économiques ou à
l'orientation à binicio des affaires
devant le conseil des prud'hommes
la commission des lois a entendu le 21
novembre dernier Jean-Marc Sauvet
présent du comité des États généraux
ainsi que Madame Arras monsieur Melun
c'est Monsieur Gavaudan président du
Conseil National des Barreaux je retiens
parmi les points évoqués outre
l'augmentation des effectifs la
nécessité de mettre en place une
véritable politique civile avec un
renforcement de la première instance là
encore le Sénat va déjà pointé ce besoin
véritable justice du quotidien qui
représente 60% du contentieux judiciaire
alors que les projecteurs sont
principalement braqués sur la justice
pénale en 2019 la justice civile
représentait en effet plus de 2 millions
200 000 décisions 2 millions 200000
décisions pour la seule justice civile
tandis que la justice pénale n'en
représentait que 800 000 ces chiffres
sont ceux de 2019 parce qu'en 2020
évidemment la crise du covid ne nous a
pas permis d'avoir un reflet réel de la
situation
pour réformer il importe que le
ministère monsieur le ministre accepte
de changer la méthode en agissant de
manière systémique au service de
justiciable et d'un meilleur
fonctionnement en évoluant en amont les
conditions pratiques nécessaires à la
réussite de ces réformes et finalement
que l'on sorte d'une approche
strictement normative à cet égard le
niveau d'exigence des études d'impact
doit être revu pour vraiment prendre en
compte la réalité du terrain trop
souvent la réforme présentée par le
gouvernement on volontairement ignorer
les effets réels induits sur
l'organisation des juridictions le
travail des juges et au final les
justiciables eux-mêmes ce type
d'approche doit impérativement être
abandonné d'ailleurs malgré les efforts
financiers accomplis ces dernières
années monsieur le ministre
la politique numérique tarde à produire
des effets concrets sur le terrain où
les équipes se plaignent encore de
dysfonctionnement notamment dû à
l'impréparation de nos réformes
législatives il faudrait en outre nos
discipliner collectivement pour modifier
les textes que lorsque cela est
strictement nécessaire est-ce un veut
pieux je ne le crois pas et juridictions
sont épuisées par les modifications
incessantes des règles et cela vaut
temps pour la loi que pour les textes
réglementaires les 12 sénateurs de la
commission des lois ont pu le constater
lors de nos stages en juridiques lors de
leur stage en juridiction cette année au
sein des tribunaux judiciaires de Paris
de Lyon de Bordeaux de Lille de Rouen ou
encore de Marseille il faut donc
désormais s'attacher à la mise en oeuvre
des propositions qu'il s'agisse des
moyens de l'organisation et du
fonctionnement de la justice ou des
réformes législatives je crois pouvoir
dire à cette tribune que le Sénat dans
son entier il veillera au final le
rapport des états le numéro de la
justice est un rapport plutôt
pragmatique et opérationnel il donne les
clés pour mieux faire fonctionner je le
crois l'existant plutôt que d'inventer
de nouveaux systèmes souvent de
caractères illusoire la mobilisation des
magistrats mais aussi celle des
greffiers qui sont moins dans la lumière
évidemment nous oblige ils sont pour la
très très grande majorité et tous sans
doute dévoués au quotidien et à la
continuité de l'institution judiciaire
il suffit de regarder ce qui s'est passé
pendant la deuxième
crise du covid ou ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui contenu certaines situations
et de travaux supplémentaires qu'ils
doivent assumer sans forcément avoir des
moyens supplémentaires malgré des
difficultés nous serions d'ailleurs je
le crois collectivement coupable de ne
pas leur apporter les moyens de leur
travail bien sûr le débat ne se résume
pas simplement à cela il y a un moment
des choix politiques à faire sur des
stratégies de justice il y a un
continuum entre la police la justice et
bien sûr la pénitentiaire pour la partie
pénale mais en toute hypothèse la
justice est en crise le chie civile les
de façon très caractéristique la justice
pénale peine surtout je le crois pas la
problématique liée à l'exécution des
peines à la rapidité de celle-ci et à
l'efficacité de celle-ci mais je ne
crois pas sincèrement que nous devons à
ce stade revoir encore et encore notre
législation certes sur un certain nombre
de points particuliers sans doute mais
je crois qu'il vaut mieux se concentrer
sur les moyens nous mettons à
disposition de nos magistrats et de nos
greffiers qu'ils soient numérique qu'il
soit humain ou qu'il soit dans une
organisation plus systémique de façon à
privilégier la réussite de cette mission
et chacun est bien conscient ici que ce
lieu de où on essaye de résoudre les
conflits entre la société Lidl quand on
entre des particuliers est à lui
absolument essentiel au fonctionnement
de notre vie tout court et de la vie
sociale en particulier c'est un lieu
d'apaisement la justice contrairement à
ce que l'on imagine c'est un lieu dans
lequel les conflits privés doivent
trouver des solutions qui apaisent les
parties qui finissent par accepter les
décisions rendues c'est absolument
fondamental aujourd'hui tous les
magistrats que nous rencontrons tous les
greffiers se rendent compte ou
s'inquiètent se posent même la question
de leur propre utilité voir de leur
reconnaissance au sein de nos
institutions c'est un bien précieux que
notre justice mes chers collègues et
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le ministre nous attendons cet
après-midi dans ce débat qui s'organise
un certain nombre de questions notamment
peut-être sur le calendrier de mise en
œuvre des conclusions des États généraux
et des concertations qui sont prévues
quand même vous avez déjà engagé mais
aussi quel type de mesure réglementaires
ou législatif souhaitez-vous engager et
enfin on nous parle on entend parler
d'un projet de loi de programmation pour
la justice à Caen ce projet sur
le pupitre du Sénat merci
la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
je suis tout particulièrement heureux de
revenir
devant vous alors que s'ouvre la
première session ordinaire de cette
nouvelle législature
je souhaite poursuivre avec chacun
d'entre vous le travail de
co-construction qui a guidé mes
relations avec le Sénat depuis mon
arrivée à la Chancellerie
c'est pourquoi dans le cadre des États
généraux qui nous réunissent aujourd'hui
je veux faire en sorte que les réformes
indispensables se fasse dans le plus
large consensus
c'est le principe même de ces états
généraux
impulsé par le Président de la
République à la demande des deux plus
hauts magistrats de notre pays qui
constitue par ailleurs un exercice
démocratique absolument inédit avec près
d'un million de contributions citoyennes
alors que le rapport de très grande
qualité
issue de ces états généraux de la
justice a été remis au Président de la
République par le président sauvé en
juillet dernier je conclus actuellement
la dernière phase de concertation de
tous les acteurs du monde judiciaire et
je veux ici un instant
saluer le Sénat dans son ensemble et en
particulier votre président Gérard
Larcher ainsi que votre président de la
commission des lois François Noel buffet
qui était d'ailleurs membre du Comité
des États généraux
pour l'engagement qui est le leur en
matière de c'est sincère monsieur
karucci
pour l'engagement qui est le leur en
matière de justice
que ce soit dans le vote des budgets
qui sont bons
il faut bien l'admettre ou bien dans les
propositions formulées je pense par
exemple
aux Agora de la justice en passant par
l'indispensable travail législatif mené
de concert je ne compte plus les fois où
le gouvernement et le Sénat ont joué
leur force avec l'Assemblée pour faire
progresser notre justice mais vous le
savez ce travail n'est pas fini loin
sans faut c'est pourquoi comme je l'ai
annoncé je présenterai dans les semaines
qui viennent
à nos concitoyens
ainsi qu'au Parlement bien sûr un plan
d'action détaillé pour réformer et
améliorer le service public de la
justice avec un impératif la rendre plus
protectrice plus rapide plus efficace
plus proche de nos concitoyens ce plan
qui je vous rassure reprendra un certain
nombre de propositions sénatoriales
comme celle concernant les recrutements
à venir ou encore la réflexion autour
d'un tribunal des affaires économiques
se déclinera à travers tous les leviers
dont nous disposons l'objectif sera pour
moi d'aller vite c'est pourquoi tout ce
qui pourra être fait par voie
réglementaire le sera et ce dans les
plus brefs délais je pense par exemple à
la matière civile ou encore à
l'organisation propre du ministère
je venait au moins vous répondre en
quelques points concernant les premières
priorités qui font déjà consensus
premièrement
nous allons poursuivre le renforcement
inédit de la justice en termes humains
et financiers car on ne résout pas 20 ou
30 ans d'abandon politique humain
financiers en un claquement de doigts
vous le savez le budget de la justice
pour
2023 sera si vous l'acceptez pour la
troisième fois consécutive en hausse de
8%
nous laisse peu à peu entrevoir
l'horizon d'une justice de qualité que
tous les acteurs du monde judiciaire
mais surtout les justiciables appellent
de leurs vœux je peux d'ores et déjà
vous annoncer qu'une première
recommandation et non des moindres du
rapport sauvé sera suivi nous
embaucherons au moins
1500 magistrats et 1500 greffiers sur le
quinquennat il s'agit là du plus grand
plan d'embauche de toute l'histoire des
services judiciaires après le volet
réglementaire budgétaire
organisationnel les arbitrages
issus des concertations en cours
prendront corps à travers une ambitieuse
loi de programmation pour la justice sur
la période 2022 2027
fidèle à la démarche de co-construction
qui est la mienne le Parlement sera très
étroitement et j'insiste consulter en
amont des débats et aura toute la place
qui lui revient au moment de l'examen de
ce texte ces discussions viseront à nous
accorder sur l'ampleur des réformes
législatives de la justice que nous
aurons apporté qu'elle soit pragmatique
programmatique ordinaire organique ou
même constitutionnel
si la loi de programmation permettra
d'inscrire dans le marbre les
recrutements massifs de magistrats de
greffiers mais aussi
de contractuels de personnels
pénitentiaires elle aura également
vocation à transposer dans la loi et de
façon concise les principales
propositions
qui ont fait pour la plupart des gens
consensus en matière pénale
mes priorités
à savoir une réponse ferme et
systématique ont été fixés par la
circulaire du 20 septembre dernier je
pense par exemple à la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et aux
mineurs lutte contre la délinquance du
quotidien et la criminalité organisée
lutte contre le terrorisme lutte contre
les atteintes à l'environnement mais
aucune politique pénale ne pourra
efficacement prospérer sans la
simplification de la procédure réclamée
par l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
judiciaire le président de la République
s'y est engagé et j'aurais donc vocation
à vous proposer une méthode consensuelle
et une feuille de route claire pour
qu'ensemble si vous en êtes d'accord
nous puissions mener ce chantier
législatif colossal la nécessité de
cette réforme fait l'objet
d'un consensus des forces de l'ordre au
magistrat en passant par les avocats
politiques pénale ne peut exister sans
politique pénitentiaire volontariste et
c'est pourquoi nous poursuivrons le
grand plan immobilier pénitentiaire avec
la création de 15000 places d'ici 2027
afin d'assurer la réponse pénale
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des agents pénitentiaires ainsi que les
conditions de détention qui nous
indignent trop souvent
sur le volet réinsertion
qui je le répète est absolument
indissociable du volet répressif nous
poursuivons la hausse des moyens alloués
ainsi que la mise en œuvre du contrat du
détenu travailleur et les remises de
peine conditionnées à l'effort en
matière civile nos objectifs sont les
suivants
pour suivre sans relâche nos efforts de
résorption des stocks
les stocks
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
matière civile ont diminué de plus de
28% au niveau national c'est absolument
considérable il faut lancer à l'échelle
nationale une politique ambitieuse de
l'amiable une décision de justice
co-construite est une décision mieux
acceptée il faut simplifier le parcours
juridictionnel du justiciable qui
ressemble il faut le dire bien souvent
un parcours du combattant
le temps imparti ne me permet pas un
exposé complet mais les questions qui
viennent me permettront d'approfondir
d'expliciter mon projet qui tient
difficilement vous me le concéderez en 8
minutes
je pense notamment parmi d'autres sujets
cruciaux question absolument
essentielles que sont la transformation
numérique du ministère
absolument essentiels et chère à votre
collègue madame la sénatrice Verrien ou
encore la justice économique et
commerciale si importante face à la
crise à venir un mot
sans aucune polémique l'attention de
Monsieur le Sénateur sueur pour lui dire
que mes avocats expriment ce qu'ils
estiment nécessaire à ma défense
deuxièmement
Madame Elisabeth Guigou pour qui j'ai le
plus profond respect
a été chargé d'un travail très important
sur la présomption d'innocence
l'impératif naturellement m'est interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous mais je vous
invite à le lire merci Monsieur
guindesseaux
alors dans la suite du débat chaque
orateur dispose de deux minutes maximum
y compris l'éventuelle réplique
et le gouvernement monsieur le garde des
sceaux dispose pour répondre d'une durée
équivalente c'est à dire deux minutes
le gouvernement s'il le souhaite aura la
faculté de répondre à une réplique
pendant une minute et l'auteur de la
question disposera alors à son tour du
droit de répondre pendant une minute
je serai le gardien du temps
la parole est à Monsieur Guy benaroche
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire donc pour deux minutes
maximum
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre les travaux de ces états
généraux s'inscrivent dans le constat à
partager d'une justice malade si vous
martelez que jamais de gouvernement n'a
autant fait pour la justice les faits
sont têtus et les chiffres
d'augmentation de budget pinte à
convaincre les acteurs du quotidien
magistrat greffiers ainsi que les
citoyens qui malgré des projets pour la
confiance dans la justice ont du mal à
appréhender un système judiciaire
souvent maltraitant notre groupe a eu
plusieurs fois l'occasion de regretter
de trop nombreuses réformes n'étant dans
l'adéquation ni avec les attentes des
citoyens ni avec des demandes de
magistrats ou de personnel pénitentiaire
voir des réformes d'affichage dans les
moyens nécessaires à leur bonne
exécution au mieux ne suivent pas au
pire ne sont même pas prévus par exemple
les nouvelles prérogatives du juge de la
liberté de la détention sans
augmentation de leur nombre ou la
généralisation des cours criminels
départementales avant de prévoir
l'arrivée de nouveaux magistrats ces
états généraux le méritent de remettre
sur la table de nombreuses discussions y
compris celle de redonner du sens à la
peine pour favoriser la la peine doit
favoriser la réinsertion de l'auteur et
réduire les risques de récidive à ce
titre en dehors des effets positifs que
cela pourrait avoir sur la population
carcérale l'idée de recentrer le juge
d'application des peines sur ces
missions premières pourraient
s'accompagner du plus grandes présence
des services pénitentiaires de
l'insertion de la probation dans des
juridictions comme cela est proposé dans
les états généraux de la justice ma
question est la suivante l'activité en
milieu ouvert des spips supérieurs en
ordre de personnes concernées comme
milieu fermé est encore trop méconnu que
comptez-vous faire pour valoriser
soutenir cette activité essentielle de
la pénitentiaire dans les compétences ne
cesse de croître
merci beaucoup la parole est à monsieur
le garde des sceaux
madame
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
monsieur le sénateur ménage
punir mes réinsérer punir et réinsérer
vous m'interrogez sur la situation des
CP alors d'abord en terme de personnel
c'est 1500 recrutements depuis 2018 ce
qui a permis de diminuer le nombre de
dossiers suivis par chaque cépip on est
passé de 80 dossiers 71 mise en place
d'organigramme de référence fixant
pardonnez-moi les effectifs affectés au
sein des cépips
en termes de revalorisation
plusieurs avancées importantes passages
en catégorie 1 revalorisation
indemnitaire de 220 euros par mois en
2022 les dépips ont bénéficié d'une
revalorisation indemnitaire de 1,3
millions en 2021 et 2022 je souhaite
aller plus loin en 2023 la poursuite de
la hausse des primes à hauteur d'un
million d'euros réforme du statut pour
faciliter la promotion professionnelle
revalorisation de leur rémunération
indiciaire à hauteur de 1,3 millions sur
le sénateur vous évoquait également le
travail en milieu ouvert s'il faut punir
le délinquant et protéger nos citoyens
avec la prison les missions réalisées
par le sepip en milieu ouvert sont
essentiels politique volontariste en
faveur des aménagements de peine et des
mesures alternatives à l'incarcération
et menée par le ministère de la Justice
en 2023 la dotation correspondant
s'élevée à 53,4 millions d'euros soit
une progression de plus 34% par rapport
à 2022 28 millions d'euros seront
consacrés au placement sous surveillance
électronique le placement extérieur
bénéficiera d'une dotation de 11,3
millions d'euros soit un complément de
2,5 millions d'euros destinés au
relèvement du prix de la journée pour
favoriser l'octroi de ces mesures enfin
la dotation allouée à la politique de
réinsertion et de lutte contre la
récidive se rapportait en 2023 à
122,5 millions d'euros merci Monsieur le
gardisso je vais être très sévère je
vais très sévère avec vous parce que en
fait il y a d'autres débats donc voilà
monsieur benaro je vous avais 21
secondes
juste pour demander la précision
suivante monsieur le ministre les moyens
que vous avez mis à disposition dans le
budget 2023
permettront-ils en fait la convergence
du régime de rémunération des directeurs
et directrices de services pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation qui sont qui
n'ont pas bénéficié de mesure depuis de
nombreuses années avec ceux de la
pénitentiaire aujourd'hui la
revalorisation des cépips fait que les
dépips c'est-à-dire que les directeurs
de ces services ont des carrières et des
inventions de carrière qui les mettent
au dessous de vos salariés de leurs
cadres la parole est à Monsieur Tani
Mohamed swahili
bien sûr vous avez le droit à une minute
avec le ministère de la Fonction
publique évidemment
merci monsieur benaroche
j'ai compris le système c'est pour ça
que je me suis permis de faire donc
monsieur le ministre j'ai compris votre
réponse qui n'en est pas vraiment une
mais je voulais rajouter plusieurs
choses la première puisque j'ai une
minute c'est que il faudrait également
veiller augmenter la dotation budgétaire
des Suisses pourquoi parce que ceux-ci
doivent pouvoir disposer de budget
propre leur permettant de financer ou de
participer au financement croisé de
prise en charge par le milieu associatif
de suivi intensifs et individualisé vous
savez qu'on peut pas y arriver sans ces
accords croisés il faudrait également
augmenter les effectifs des cépips je
comprends bien que vous avez dit qu'ils
ont augmenté mais vous savez qu'il y a
un ratio qui a été fixé le ratio il a
été fixé d'un agent pour 60 personnes
suivies vous avez vous-même dit
qu'actuellement on est à un agent pour
71 personnes suivies donc nous n'avons
pas atteint le ratio qui était prévu je
termine dans les temps Madame la
Présidente si beaucoup donc la parole à
Monsieur d'animaux Ahmed Soignies pour
le groupe RDPI
merci madame la Présidente constat
sévère au bord de la rupture état de
délabrement avancé crise majeure perte
de sens on ne compte plus les
qualificatifs moribonds pour décrire la
justice au son fonctionnement dans notre
pays le rapport du Comité des États
généraux remis au Président de la
République le 8 juillet dernier a
formulé une série de recommandations
pour redresser le service public de la
justice il souligne que sans
renforcement des moyens financiers
humains et un matériel les réformes
resteront déconnectées de leur capacités
d'application aussi et pour la troisième
année le budget consacré à la justice et
en hausse dans le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 en 5 ans il a augmenté
de plus de 40% avec près de 700
magistrats 850 greffiers et plus de 2000
juristes recrutés ce qui est historique
cette nouvelle augmentation de 8%
permettra à la création de 2253 emplois
en équivalent temps plein dans son
rapport le Comité relève a juste titre
que l'ensemble des constats sur la
justice sont aggravés à notre mère et
que la défiance envers l'institution y
est plus accrue c'est le cas du déficit
et de la mauvaise gestion des moyens
humains à Mayotte et en Guyane par
exemple les acteurs de la justice se
plaignent d'une désorganisation
permanente des juridictions liées à un
fort absentéisme des magistrats et des
greffiers épuisés par leurs charges et
conditions de travail la dépendance
financière des juridictions de Guyane ou
de Mayotte empêche de répondre
directement et efficacement aux besoins
de ces territoires c'est le cas
également du manque de réponse pénale en
dehors de la prison elle-même en crise
sévère c'est enfin le cas de la fracture
numérique démultiplier un autre mer
monsieur le garde des sceaux je vous
sais concerné par les problèmes que
rencontre à notre mère nos citoyens dans
l'accès à la justice et les acteurs du
monde judiciaire dans leur travail vous
présenterez prochainement un plan
d'action et une loi de programmation
pour la justice comment entendez-vous
ventiler crédit et moyen dans ces
territoires reculés afin d'y relever les
défis constatés
comment vous dire je suis très préoccupé
évidemment par la situation
guyanaise et Mahrez je rentre de Guyane
je me suis rendu avec Gérald Darmanin
Gabriel Attal nous avons renforcé
considérablement les moyens douaniers
force de sécurité
et magistrats et greffiers le problème
principal est un problème d'attractivité
et nous avons créé à la Chancellerie une
brigade de soutien qui consiste à
demander à des magistrats métropolitains
de partir six mois et un jour le jour
pour des raisons fiscales que vous avez
évidemment comprises et pour aider les
magistrats sur place alors nous allons
dupliquer cela nous mettons en place en
Guyane nous le mettrons en place à
Mayotte bien évidemment et nous
enverrons des personnels supplémentaires
j'ai par ailleurs lorsque je me suis
déplacé à Mayotte indiqué que pour un
magistrat pour un greffier se rendre à
Mayotte ça devait être un tremplin et
nous faisons en short que au sortir de
Mayotte les greffiers les magistrats
sachent exactement où ils seront nommés
ou plus exactement renommés alors il y a
évidemment des opérations immobilières
importantes qui sont prévues cité du
ministère de la Justice à
Saint-Laurent-du-Maroni cité judiciaire
à Cayenne cité judiciaire et centre
éducatif fermé à Mayotte et bientôt un
deuxième établissement pénitentiaire les
outre-mer ont besoin évidemment de
davantage de moyens nous le savons je
souligne ici l'engagement total qui est
le vôtre à la fois pour votre territoire
mais également pour la justice vous êtes
toujours monsieur sénateur au
rendez-vous et vous nous rappelez ce que
nous devons faire et ce que vous dites
nous oblige
la parole est à Madame Laurence arrivée
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain merci Madame présidente
monsieur le ministre le rapport des
États généraux préconise l'augmentation
des conseillers pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation mais pas
seulement il préconise aussi la
généralisation de la présence de
psychologues dans tous les services
c'est une nécessité que nous avons
largement mesuré lors de notre mission
d'évaluation sur les spips avec ma
collègue Marie Mercier nous avons aussi
pu constater que le faible nombre des
assistants sociaux un par département
seulement pourtant fondamentaux puisque
les sepip évoluent vers un métier qui
est plus de mesurer le risque de récidif
plutôt que la seule réinsertion donc la
question est simple quelle suite allez
vous donner à ce volet sur
l'interdisciplinarité à l'intérieur des
spips d'autre part nous avons aussi
remarqué un problème d'attractivité un
manque d'accompagnement face à
l'évolution même des métiers la
nécessité d'un écosystème des acteurs en
la matière quelle suite voulez-vous
donner au rapport
si monsieur le garde des sceaux c'est la
parole
vous poser la question très importante
que celle de l'interdisciplinarité je
voudrais vous dire que c'est la boussole
qui est la nôtre pour les recrutements
qui sont à venir j'ai déjà répondu tout
à l'heure monsieur le sénateur benarus
sur l'intérêt évidemment que nous
portions au s'épips qui sont absolument
indispensables je rappelle pour mémoire
1500 CP engagés depuis 2018 j'ai rappelé
tout à l'heure les revalorisations ce
qui témoignent évidemment de l'intérêt
que nous portons à cette profession que
nous considérons comme absolument
essentiel dans la politique de
réinsertion et de lutte contre la
récidive des personnes placées sous-main
justice
la priorité c'est évidemment de
valoriser le travail des cépips dont
l'embaucher davantage j'ai souhaité que
la dotation allouée en 2023 soit portée
à 122,5 millions soit plus 12,9 millions
d'euros qui représente ce qui représente
une hausse de 13% par rapport 2022
politique active de préparation à la
sortie à la réinsertion en lien étroit
avec les services de l'État les
collectivité territoriales bien sûr et
les partenaires privés mais également
les dispositifs de formation
professionnelle des personnes détenues
et le développement du travail en
détention auquel je suis vous le savez
particulièrement attaché
l'interdisciplinarité pour revenir à la
question
c'est une réponse bien sûr que nous
envisageons il n'est pas possible
d'ailleurs de faire autrement il est
logique que cette interdisciplinarité
trouve écho dans les recrutements à
venir
arrivée vous avez 51 secondes je vous
interrogeais plus que sur les sepips sur
les assistances sociaux puisque vous
aviez déjà répondu en partie sur les CP
en fait on est bien à la croisée des
chemins dans ce domaine-là avec de
nouveaux métiers et une approche
beaucoup plus transdisciplinaire nous
sommes passés en gros d'une culture
d'assistance sociale et d'accompagnement
à l'insertion à une culture plutôt de la
mesure du risque de récidive pour
laisser pips d'où la nécessité d'autres
métiers à côté et d'une et pour plaider
une autre ingénierie de la sanction et
ceci nous ramène aussi à des éléments
que nous avons vu dans la mission
d'information relative à la lutte de la
délinquance des mineurs et qui est du
même type il est clair que
l'augmentation du nombre de places dans
les prisons n'est pas la solution et
c'est ce que dit très clairement le
rapport sauvé merci
la parole est à madame Cécile cuckermann
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste merci madame la
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues le rapport du groupe
de travail sur la simplification de la
procédure pénale prévoit à
l'intronisation de l'intelligence
artificielle comme outil d'aide à la
décision pénale certes le droit pénal la
procédure pénale sont devenues très
complexes certes je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui rejettent la science et la
technologie quand elles apportent à
l'émancipation humaine pour autant le
recours à l'intelligence artificielle
lors du jugement n'est-ce pas avoir
recours à un juge robot déshumanisé à
une justice qui entre dans une logique
d'automaticité perdant ainsi tout son
sens son sens premier à savoir rendre
justice au nom de tous en prenant en
compte la situation de chacun
monsieur le garde des sceaux
madame la sénatrice mais je pense que
nous préférons une justice humaine
merveilleusement humaine parfois
terriblement humaine à n'importe quel
robot s'il suffisait d'introduire je ne
sais quelle carte quelle carte
informatisé dans une machine pour avoir
les solutions
je crois que d'abord nous n'aurions plus
de raison d'être il y aurait plus de
difficultés et plus de problématique moi
je suis très attaché comme vous à
l'indépendance de la justice
l'indépendance a pour corollaire que
parfois certaines décisions qui sont
vendues peuvent nous faire un petit quai
oui mais dans les états totalitaires la
justice est à la botte voilà moi je
préfère une justice indépendante et
d'ailleurs on ne parle que des choses
qui vont mal jamais de celles qui vont
bien ils sont quand même extrêmement
majoritaires donc oui je préfère une
justice humaine qui peut se tromper à
une justice informatisée
voilà ma réponse est je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord là-dessus la
personnalisation de la peine par exemple
je sais pas trop comment l'intelligence
artificielle pourrait se débrouiller
avec ça vous voyez je me pose
franchement la question et j'ai pas
trouvé la réponse
[Musique]
vous avez une
mythique bien évidemment l'humain
d'abord mais je ne l'ai pas fait pensant
que cela était tellement évident venant
des propos de notre groupe que j'ai
évité cette répétition inutile ici dans
l'hémicycle plus sincèrement et plus
sérieusement effectivement
nous pensons et nous l'avons toujours
défendu que la justice ne peut se passer
de l'humain de cette émotion et qui
comme toute émotion parfois est aussi
contestable mais qui en tout cas permet
de rendre une justice la plus juste
possible je reprendrai d'ici et sans
aucun parallèle avec quelques actualités
que ce soit les propos du président
buffet dans son intervention limitaire
limitaire la justice est effectivement
un lieu qui apaise pour pouvoir apaiser
elle a besoin de ses moyens humains qui
écoutent qui entendent qui parfois
répare qui parfois réinsère qui parfois
juge qui parfois contrôle les lieux y
compris de prévention de privation de la
de la liberté mais en tout cas cette
justice qui apaise est indispensable de
notre société à la différence d'un
jugement sur la place publique qui au
contraire hystérise cristallise et
oppose les gens entre eux
si la parole est à Madame Dominique
verrière pour le groupe Union centriste
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc en
cette rentrée par le mental je crois
qu'il est important de tout de suite
reprendre nos bonnes habitudes et ainsi
monsieur le ministre vous avez raison
sans surprise je vais vous parler
d'informatique en effet je vous alerte
depuis longtemps sur cet aspect en
particulier sur les logiciels cassiopés
en tête c'est une question plus centrale
qu'il n'y paraît tant le personnel de
justice peut se retrouver découragé face
à des applicatifs obsolescents qui
accumulent les lourdeurs les
incompatibilités et les bugs votre
ministère parle même de goût amer
laissez aux agents comme le note le
rapport des états généraux de la justice
ainsi le comité en appelle ni plus ni
moins à une refondation complète de la
maîtrise d'ouvrage informatique ainsi
qu'à la fondation d'un véritable socle
informatique commun à la fois au sein de
la justice mais aussi avec des
ministères partenaires l'intérieur par
exemple et pour mémoire la procédure
pénale numérique qui se met en place
souffre elle aussi des bugs de Cassiopée
en particulier dans le cadre des
transferts entre gendarmerie et justice
comme j'ai pu constater moi-même dans
une gendarmerie à Toucy ma question est
donc simple monsieur le ministre quel
plan d'action entendez-vous mettre en
œuvre à ce titre le ministère de
l'intérieur par la loi locmi en tant que
créer une agence numérique une seule
agence pour les deux ministères
serait-elle envisageable
merci monsieur le garde des sceaux
la sénatrice verrière on travaille en
concertation avec Bercy pour répondre à
la préoccupation légitime qui est la
vôtre j'ai nommé il y a peu de temps un
secrétaire général adjoint du ministère
qui est dédié au numérique nous avons
été vous le savez ça n'a échappé à
personne critiquée par la Cour des
comptes mais la Cour des comptes à
cependant indiquée que nous avions fait
beaucoup d'efforts et je compte
évidemment les poursuivre le
rapprochement des maîtrises d'ouvrages
et maîtrise d'oeuvre projet par projet
est une priorité clairement identifiée
et ça permettra au projet de gagner en
cohérence et en efficacité mais je vais
vous dire deux choses d'une part je
crois pas qu'il y ait en la matière
modèle unique
qui serait le plus efficace pour tous
les ministères et d'autre part j'entends
vraiment que le ministère au-delà de sa
spécificité ne soit plus perçue comme le
Ministère des vieilles pierres mais
comme un ministère moderne efficace
exemplaire dans sa gouvernance son
exécution budgétaire ces indicateurs que
nous venons d'imposer je serais donc
très attentif à ce que par exemple la
gouvernance numérique s'est organisée de
la meilleure manière possible et je ne
doute pas que je serai interrogé dans un
avenir proche sur
ce que nous avons fait pour mettre en
ordre dans notre ministère le numérique
je suis d'accord avec vous enfin le
sujet de la transformation est majeur
pour l'avenir de ce ministère bien sûr
et nous aurons je suis sûr de cela
l'occasion d'en débattre ne fut-ce qu'à
l'occasion du débat sur le budget voilà
madame la rapporteur j'espère vous avoir
rassuré un peu
merci mais rien vous avez 30 secondes
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
alors vous parliez de Bercy
effectivement vous avez une interface
pour le paiement des amendes qui semble
être fait par Bercy et qui fonctionne
bien parce que pour le coup ils ont très
bien su eux se mettre en ordre de marche
niveau informatique pour prendre nos
sous ce serait bien qu'on puisse nous
aussi avancer pour pouvoir rendre la
justice et par ailleurs on ne peut pas
ne pas travailler avec le ministère de
l'intérieur parce que la procédure
pénale numérique concerne l'ensemble des
deux ministères et il faut que les gens
puissent se parler merci Madame Esther
Benbassa
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
conclusions des états généraux de la
justice confirment l'état déplorable de
notre institution judiciaire une des
premières décisions du garde des sceaux
fut d'augmenter les magistrats
judiciaires de 1000 euros je salue cette
initiative mais les magiciens et
greffiers souffrent surtout du manque de
moyens humains et matériel dans quelques
semaines nous étudierons le projet de
loi des finances pour l'année 2023 il
nous appartiendra d'être
particulièrement exigeant sur la
répartition des crédits le texte annuel
annoncé prévoit une nouvelle hausse de
8%, cela représente 710 millions
supplémentaires sur l'année dernière
dont 41% reviendrait à l'administration
pénitentielle je me réjouis quand tel
budget soit alloué aux établissements
pénitentiaires toutefois j'aimais
quelques réserves sur ces dépenses qui
concernerait grande partie le parc
immobilier pénitentiaire monsieur le
ministre je comprends votre volonté de
mettre fin à la surpopulation carcérale
mais la construction des prisons comme
vous le savez n'est pas la seule
solution plus on construit plus on
remplit la réponse à ce problème
structurel se trouve du côté de la
prévention de la récidive de la
réinsertion et des peines de
substitution sous certaines conditions
je pose donc la question la loi des
finances pour 2022 accordée aux
alternatives à l'incarcération un budget
standard de à 39,8 millions d'euros
compte près d'un milliards d'euros
d'investissement immobilier
pénitentiaire pour
2023 comment comptez-vous répartir
l'enveloppe budgétaire entre insertion
et alternative à la prison je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le gardeesseau
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
puisque vous m'y invité je vais vous
répondre sur le registre budgétaire
alors vous l'avez indiqué la
programmation immobilière de 15000
places 15000 nouvelles places absolument
essentielles pour mettre fin à la
surpopulation pénale ça n'est pas
évidemment la seule solution je pense
évidemment aux conditions indignes bien
sûr j'y attache comme vous d'ailleurs
une attention toute particulière
l'émission réalisée par le SPIP
notamment au milieu ouvert tout aussi
essentiel et doivent continuer à se
développer le ministère poursuit une
politique volontariste en faveur des
mesures alternatives à l'incarcération
des aménagements de peine et en 2023
pour répondre précisément à votre
question la dotation correspondante
s'élèvera à
53,4 millions d'euros soit une
progression de plus 34% par rapport à
2022 28 millions seront consacrés au
placement sous surveillance électronique
le placement extérieur bénéficiera d'une
dotation de
11,3 millions d'euros soit un complément
de 2,5 millions d'euros destinés au
relèvement du prix de la journée pour
favoriser l'axe 3 de ces mesures
2,6 millions sont prévus pour
accompagner le déploiement du contrôle
judiciaire sous placement probatoire
enfin la dotation allouée à la politique
de réinsertion des personnes placées
sous-maine de justice sera elle aussi
portée en 2023
122,5 millions c'est une hausse de 13%
par rapport à 2022 vous savez d'ailleurs
madame la sénatrice ou l'attachement que
je porte au sens du travail l'effort des
publics qui exécute une peine qu'elle
soit accomplie en milieu ouvert ou en
détention et je vais naturellement
favoriser le travail et la venue massive
de ceux qui peuvent offrir ce travail ce
qui permet bien sûr une meilleure
réinsertion
merci
vous n'avez que 8 secondes pour
remercier monsieur le garde des sceaux
bon merci monsieur le ministre mais je
voudrais vous demander qu'il y ait
prochainement un état des lieux des
lieux de privation de liberté et qu'on
aborde spécifiquement ce sujet même s'il
a aimé abordé dans les états collègues
de la justice merci la parole est à
Madame Nathalie Delattre pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le 13 septembre 2021 je
déposais une proposition de loi pour
développer le recours à la médiation le
groupement européen des magistrats pour
la médiation et plusieurs autres acteurs
du monde judiciaire relever le caractère
essentiel de cette proposition si du
chemin reste à faire pour promouvoir le
recours à la médiation dans notre pays
je tiens à vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre pour l'engagement personnel qui
est le vôtre dans le développement de ce
dispos notamment en réaction des peaux
du rapport des états généraux de la
justice de nos jours le recours à la
médiation est encore trop peu développé
en France même si des expériences
ponctuelles comme au référé du tribunal
judiciaire de Paris donne d'excellents
résultats d'autant que l'usage de
dispositif est fortement encouragé par
nos concitoyens en effet dans un sondage
du CSA réalisé pour le Sénat en 2021 90%
des Français interrogés plébisciter le
recours à la médiation et à la
conciliation la médiation est un outil
précieux pour notre système juridique
permettant aux justiciables de se
réapproprier le procès en en devenant
des acteurs responsables il permet de
résoudre des situations qui semblaient
bloquer en renouant le dialogue avec
l'aide d'un tiers compétent neutre et
impartial
en 2021 la loi pour la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire a marqué une
étape en facilitant le recours à la
médiation et en actant la création du
Conseil national pour la médiation mais
il est nécessaire d'aller plus loin et
d'engager une véritable politique
nationale de l'amiable judiciaire dans
notre pays monsieur le gardeesseau
pouvez-vous m'assurer que vous
développerez le recours à la médiation
en faisant évoluer la loi ma PPL est à
votre disposition en attendant envisage
auriez-vous de prendre rapidement des
mesures concrètes en valorisant la
médiation dans l'organisation des
juridictions en développant la formation
des acteurs judiciaires et en adoptant
des mesures incitatives je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le garder son
je sais madame la Présidente sévère et
s'il me fallait vous répondre en trois
mots je dirais oui oui et oui bon
d'abord je crois je crois en la
médiation parce que une décision à
laquelle on a participé est une décision
qu'on accepte mieux par ailleurs ça nous
économise si j'ose dire du temps
judiciaire que l'on peut consacrer par
exemple au déstockage vous verrez que
dans ces états généraux de la justice la
médiation ressort de façon très
consensuelle et même une procédure dont
je j'aurais évidemment l'honneur et le
plaisir de vous reparler qui est une
procédure de césure nous nous sommes
inspirés de l'étranger on a uniformisé
vous vous l'avez rappelé la liste des
médiateurs actualiser les formulaires de
candidature on a triplé la rétribution
aide juridictionnelle pour les avocats
qui participent à la médiation tout cela
vous l'avez rappelé je sais que vous
portez un texte et je serais vraiment
ravi je le dis que vous veniez
la Chancellerie qu'on puisse ensemble
évoquer l'ensemble de ces questions le
civil est extrêmement important monsieur
le Président fait la rappeler et nous
n'avons pas encore arbitré madame la
sénatrice nous discutons encore j'ai
souhaité vraiment que tout le monde soit
associé à ces états généraux venait à la
Chancellerie c'est une invitation
naturellement et pas un impératif et
nous évoquerons ces questions parce
qu'il faut faire progresser la médiation
voilà je pense que c'est la justice de
demain à l'évidence voilà
je vous attends
merci
la parole est à Madame Agnès canaillé
pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur garde des
sceaux mes chers collègues donc la
confiance dans nos institutions et le
cœur de notre pacte républicain et aux
côtés du pouvoir législatif et exécutif
la justice participe grandement à cet
enjeu fondamental je me félicite du
travail qui a été mené par les États
généraux de la justice de manière
systémique globale et associant
l'ensemble des acteurs pour mettre en
place des pistes de réflexion d'ampleur
mais on voit aujourd'hui que le travail
est abyssal et que il va nécessiter
effectivement beaucoup d'investissement
mais aussi une priorisation donc
j'entends que vous avez une méthode et
que vous allez pouvoir définir de
manière concertée ces axes de
priorisation mais comme l'ajustement
rappelé le président de la commission
des lois dans la priorisation et pour
redonner confiance il faut d'abord la
proximité la justice du quotidien bien
celle qui correspond
aux besoins de chaque jour c'est avant
tout la justice civile et au sein de
cette justice civile il y a un sujet qui
nous tient à cœur alors le collègue la
vie se présente de Lattre la vie se
présente grunis et Corinne Fréret nous
avons remis un rapport sur la justice
prud'homale qu'il y a déjà trois ans
faisait de nombreuses propositions pour
justement restaurer cette confiance sur
cette justice du travail cette justice
du quotidien alors que aujourd'hui bien
que le nombre d'affaires est largement
diminué moins
55%, les délais de jugement restent très
longs autour de 16 mois on le voit bien
qu'il y a un besoin de réforme
systémique donc cette réforme de la
justice prudomal monsieur le garde des
sceaux est-elle dans vos priorités
c'est dire que je me répète mais la
réponse est oui bien sûr alors je
connais évidemment votre rapport
question de temporalité puisque
évidemment on ne peut il y a eu un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
faites je vais pas les rappeler ici je
pense pas que nous ayons chômé que nous
ayons perdu notre temps mais voilà venu
le moment effectivement de réfléchir à
nouveau sur la justice prudomale parce
que ce que nous souhaitons c'est une
justice plus proche c'est une justice
plus rapide c'est une justice plus
efficace et donc les propositions qui
ont été faites seront intégrés
évidemment dans ces états généraux et de
la même façon je l'ai fait tout à
l'heure je vous invite évidemment à
venir partager avec moi un certain
nombre de solutions que vous souhaitez
voir reprise les arbitrages une fois
encore ne sont pas terminés je suis tout
à fait ouvert à cela
s'il me reste oui il me reste un peu de
temps je voudrais vous dire un peu
quelle est la méthode que nous avons
mise en place moi je ne suis pas
intervenu ni dans le comité des états
qui a été mis en place ni dans les
différents ateliers de travail je ne
voulais pas que l'on dise que c'était ce
que souhaitait le ministre au fond et
puis quand le rapport Sauvé a été rendu
ainsi que les annexes j'ai réuni tout le
monde et ce que je souhaite garder c'est
ce qui est consensuel
voilà ce qui m'importe je suis un peu
une autre méthodologie une autre
gouvernance ce n'est pas caporaliste ça
vient pas du haut pour irriguer vers le
bas c'est une discussion avec tout le
monde les conférences les syndicats qui
ont voulu venir sont pas tous venus mais
peu importe c'est leur problème une
porte que l'on ne franchit pas n'est pas
une porte fermée donc voilà un peu la
méthode et donc il se dégage des choses
très consensuelles je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises pardon de me répéter
mais c'est comme ça qu'on va progresser
sur ces états généraux parce que c'est
l'affaire de tous et je pense que tout
le monde a compris que c'était un moment
historique et important pour notre
justice donc bienvenue madame la
sénatrice merci
merci Monsieur le gardeesseau bien
évidemment nous participerons pour
pouvoir étoffer la réflexion j'entends
cette demande de consensus néanmoins il
est important aussi que certaines
réformes s'imposent à un moment donné et
que s'ils consensus peut-être nécessaire
je pense que c'est des réformes elles
doivent être aussi d'ampleur et
systématiques la justice prud'homale
pour revenir sur le sujet est quand même
au milieu du gué et ça demande d'aller
vraiment beaucoup plus loin merci la
parole est à Monsieur Dany ouate pour le
groupe Les Indépendants merci à ma
présidente monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues dans notre pays
la justice en crise du Pitron alors que
le gouvernance soit prête à consentir
par trois années consécutive un effort
budgétaire sans précédent les
difficultés n'ont toujours pas été
surmontées à l'occasion des états
généraux de la justice plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de contributions de
nos concitoyens tant profils de droit
que simple justiciables ont été
recueillis
elles ont suivi la place fondamentale du
récit de la justice au sein de notre
société démocratique et notre trade de
droit il est crucial qu'elle fonctionne
correctement et efficacement non
seulement pour les parties mais
également pour l'ensemble de notre
société
le rapport du Comité des agiraux de la
justice rappelle qu'entre 2009 et 2020
le code pénal a été modifié par 11 lois
chaque année en moyenne et le code de
procédure pénale par 17 lois
cette évolution complexifie à pas douter
le quotidien des policiers des gendarmes
est rallonge les procédures
au-delà de l'inflation normative le
rapport estime que la refonte de la
procédure pénale est nécessaire il se
prononce en faveur du maintien du juge
d'instruction mais surtout envisage
d'unifier les cadres d'enquête de
flagrance et de l'enquête préliminaire
il propose pour se faire de conduire une
suite d'impact sur les différents
scénarios de l'unification des régimes
d'enquête monsieur le gardeesseau
comptez-vous mener cette étude d'impact
et que pensez-vous de l'offre de la
fusil de cette fusion
si monsieur le garde des sceaux
merci madame la Présidente
parmi les choses qui font qu'on s'insus
et accords il y a la simplification la
nécessité pardon de simplifier la
procédure pénale
vous l'avez dit il y a une
multiplication de textes qui sont venus
complexifier la procédure pénale au
point que les professionnels disent même
que on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de mal à
s'y retrouver
donc on envisage une simplification
les policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats et les greffiers les avocats
à la demande il y a une unification des
délais par exemple il y a la question de
l'enquête préliminaire et de l'enquête
de flagrance
on ne peut pas cependant supprimer la
notion de flagrance qui figure je le
rappelle à l'article 26 de la
Constitution et qui permet d'ailleurs
d'arrêter sans autorisation du bureau de
l'Assemblée ou du Sénat un parlementaire
en cas de crimes flagrant bon
ce petit clin d'oeil mis à part oui il y
a beaucoup de choses qui peuvent être
simplifiées en étant évidemment
respectueux des droits de la défense des
libertés individuelles des libertés
publiques et ces vers cela que nous
irons ce travail on estime qu'il va
durer deux ans et je dis parce que c'est
une réalité que bien sûr les
parlementaires seront associés de près à
l'élaboration de ce travail et que les
études d'impact seront conduites bien
sûr parce que on ne peut pas en la
matière avancer à l'aveugle donc soyez
parfaitement rassuré nous avons commencé
bien sûr à travailler sur ces sujets ils
sont colossaux c'est extrêmement
ambitieux mais le Parlement sera associé
à ce travail qui est aujourd'hui un
travail demandé et un travail absolument
indispensable merci monsieur vous avez
25 secondes
un peu de temps merci votre réponse
monsieur
merci de la parole est à monsieur
Jean-Yves Lecomte pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous vous
savons monsieur le garde Deschaux
attaché au renforcement de
l'indépendance du parquet et nous
partageons nombreux ici sur ces bancs le
souhait de voir enfin aboutir une
réforme du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature permettant d'y parvenir
en effet la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme refuse d'assimiler le
ministère public français à une
véritable autorité judiciaire ressemble
au sens de l'article 5 de la Convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme qui garantit le droit à la
liberté et à la sûreté le Sénat avait
adopté en juillet 2013 un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui avait pour objectif
de renforcer l'autorité du CSM est de
mieux garantir l'indépendance et
l'impartialité des magistrats
malheureusement il aurait fallu attendre
avril 2016 pour que ce texte soit voté
en termes identique par l'Assemblée
nationale et puis plus rien près de deux
ans plus tard lors de l'audience
solennelle de rentrer de la Cour de
cassation en janvier 2018 le président
de la République avait lui aussi affirmé
ce souhait de renforcer l'indépendance
du ministère public et indiquer que la
réforme se préparerait que préparer
votre à leur prédécesseur madame Nicole
Belloubet devait intégrer ces éléments
il y a une quinzaine de jours au sujet
du statut du parquet lors de son
audition par la commission des Lois du
Sénat à l'occasion du rapport remis sur
les états généraux de la justice
Monsieur Jean-Marc Sauvet a d'ailleurs
indiqué qu'il avait eu à soumettre
président de la République un décret de
convocation du congrès sur cette réforme
puis je cite un décret je cite de
démontage du Congrès ajoutant que
c'était la seule fois dans l'histoire de
la République quand elle acte avait été
pris
aujourd'hui je souhaitais monsieur le
garde des sceaux savoir si vous pouviez
nous éclairer sur le calendrier relatif
à cette nécessaire réforme pour qu'enfin
puisse être effectif le renforcement de
l'indépendance du parquet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur Leconte je n'ai pas de réponse
calendaire à vous fournir on va redire
les choses vous les avez d'ailleurs pour
partir à plein
réforme du statut du parking peut se
faire que par une modification d'article
65 de la Constitution
le rapport sauvé l'évoque dans des
termes que vous avez rappelé
Dijon pour être tout à fait
précis que cette proposition ne fait pas
consensus qu'elle est aujourd'hui
discutée et moi je vous propose de
mettre ce sujet à l'ordre du jour de la
commission transpartisane voilà sur les
précisions calendaires vous comprendrez
bien sûr que je suis incapable de vous
en dire davantage
merci Monsieur le Comte vous avez 23
secondes
Présidente nous avons absolument besoin
d'avancer sur un sujet essentiel pour
notre État de droit surtout si l'on
parle aujourd'hui de les états généraux
de la justice le développement des
missions des procureurs de la République
exigent cette réforme de la même manière
compte tenu des débats sur l'état de
droit dans l'Union européenne et du rôle
que joue la France dans ce débat nous
avons besoin d'être exemplaire et de de
faire évoluer de répondre à l'ensemble
des exigences merci la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe bonne Carrère Union
centriste
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre mais chers collègues le
rapport sur les états généraux de la
justice insiste sur le fait que la
justice connaît une crise dite
systémique mots a d'ailleurs été employé
dans la bouche de mes d'une de mes
collègues tout à l'heure lorsque l'on
regarde les réponses qui vous sont
fournis ou qui sont fournis au président
de la République dans le cas du rapport
forcé de constater que les mesures
elles-mêmes sont sectoriales on voit
immédiatement que face à une crise
systémique la question est de savoir par
quel bout prendre ce sujet on vous
écoutant tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
entendu la référence en plan d'action
détaillé à des volets réglementaires à
une loi de programmation 2022 2027 à une
feuille de route sur la réforme de la
procédure pénale à une nouvelle
politique pénitentiaire à une politique
ambitieuse de on voit bien que les
priorités sont multiples et vous savez
monsieur le garde des sceaux que quand
tout est prioritaire il n'y a plus de
priorité et donc j'ai finalement deux
questions à vous poser la première
quelle serait votre priorité et la
deuxième c'est est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas une autre approche de ce sujet qui
consisterait à tirer les conséquences et
les avantages de l'effort budgétaire
massif que vous avez obtenus vous en
fera il faut vous en faire crédit de
laisser les recrutements
sortir leurs effets dans le monde de la
justice les nouveaux moyens financiers
finalement stabiliser la structure et
passer ensuite dans un deuxième temps à
une série de réformes du sectorielles
même si on sent bien que vous bouillez
d'impatience sur ces sujets donc
également quelle temporalité dans la
gestion de ces sujets
[Applaudissements]
en même temps dans tout ça
non d'abord budgétaire bon sans les
moyens
rien n'est possible ensuite renforcement
bien sûr grâce à ce budget des moyens
humains très attendus par tout le monde
tout à l'heure d'entre vous a rappelé ce
que nous avions fait en termes
d'embauche je vais pas le rappeler ici
nous avons dit 10 000 personnels
supplémentaires 1500 magistrats 1500
greffiers décontractuel ensuite le civil
et le civil de façon réglementaire on ne
pourra pas me reprocher comment
dirais-je une loi une loi nouvelle une
inflation législative mais naturellement
vous serez associé
au réglementaires et de près ce
réglementaire civil il a pour objet on
l'a évoqué d'aller vers davantage de de
médiation de simplifier cela ensuite
bien sûr il y aura du législatif
une loi de programmation bien sûr la
réforme de la procédure pénale et très
vraisemblablement une loi organique
puisque les états généraux de la justice
évoquent un certain nombre de
modifications qui nous conduisent à
passer par la loi
tout ça va se conduire si j'ose dire en
même temps en tous les cas rapidement
moi je veux aller vite le règlementaire
très bien loi de programmation pour
janvier
2023 début d'année pour que l'on ait un
étalement jusque la fin du quinquennat
et puis le reste naturellement suivra
son cours j'allais dire
ordinaire mais le consensus me permettra
je le crois
d'obtenir l'adhésion des parlementaires
parce que je me dis et c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui a guidé ma réflexion si tout le
monde est d'accord force de sécurité
intérieure magistrat greffier avocat
mais je pense que les parlementaires
constateront cet accord et qu'ils n'ont
qu'une envie aussi c'est d'améliorer la
justice du quotidien voilà monsieur le
sénateur ce que je peux vous répondre à
ce stade merci la parole est à Monsieur
Antoine Lefebvre pour le groupe les
républicains
précédente monsieur le garder ce mes
chers collègues les états généraux de la
Justice ont été convoqués à point nommés
alors que l'institution judiciaire
semblait condamner à s'enfoncer toujours
plus dans la détresse souligné par les
conclusions du rapport il est impératif
aujourd'hui de ne pas se laisser de ne
pas laisser s'éteindre la dynamique qui
est né de cette large concertation cela
a été dit maintes et maintes fois je le
redirai une fois de plus ici la toute
première urgence de notre tribunaux et
celle du renforcement des moyens humains
proportionnellement au volume du
contentieux en attente de jugement c'est
pourquoi s'il est important de saluer la
revalorisation salariale des magistrats
que vous avez appelé de vos vœux le 12
septembre dernier celle-ci ne doit pas
faire oublier la véritable priorité
financière de l'institution judiciaire
qui est celle de sortir ces tribunaux de
la désérance et ces outils informatiques
de l'archaïsme je solliciterai monsieur
le ministre vos précisions sur le point
suivant les directeurs pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation vous ont
récemment fait part de leur souhait de
voir engager une réforme de valorisation
de leur statut et de leurs indemnités
cette revendication
bien après qu'une amélioration apportée
en 2017 au statut des conseillers
d'insertion de probation à effacer les
différences de traitement et de statuts
entre les deux corps pourtant
hiérarchiquement distinctes la
responsabilité exercée par les
directeurs sur les conseillers
d'insertion souffrent ainsi d'une perte
de légitimité préjudiciable au bon
exercice de leur mission à cela s'ajoute
l'importance perte d'attractivité du
métier qui a déjà conduit cet été à ce
que seul si postes sur les 22 proposés
au concours interne soit pourvu les
demandes de détachement à l'extérieur
quant à elles ont triplé en 4 ans ma
question monsieur le ministre est donc
la suivante quelle place souhaitez-vous
accorder au revendications des
directeurs d'insertion et de probation
dans les chantiers que vous souhaiterez
entreprendre à la lumière des
conclusions de ces états généraux je
vous remercie merci monsieur le garde
des sceaux
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
sénateur Lefebvre vous m'interrogez sur
ce que le ministère compte faire pour
rendre le métier de dépipe plus
attractif bon il est vrai que les
réformes interministérielles qui ont été
engagées depuis 2017 ont abouti à
revaloriser les salaires des conseillers
pénitentiaires mais pas ceux des
directeurs et il en est il en est de
même d'ailleurs pour les directeurs des
services de la Protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse alors concernant les
dépiques les dépips c'est le sujet de
votre question le ministère s'engage en
2022 c'est en cours à revaloriser les
primes des dépipes d'environ 700 000
euros qui viennent s'ajouter aux 600 000
euros qui ont été octroyés à ce corps en
2021 et en 2023 je porterai la poursuite
de la hausse des primes à hauteur d'un
million d'euros une réforme du statut
pour faciliter la promotion
professionnelle et les parcours de
carrière plus attractifs et
revalorisation de leur rémunération
indiciaire à hauteur de 1,3 millions
d'euros ces évolutions sont évidemment
légitimes nous avons reçu il y a
quelques jours de cela les représentants
des dépits et je pense que ils savent
bien sûr ce que nous comptons faire et
ce que nous comptons faire vous l'avez
vous-même souligné c'est mettre
comment dirais on avant bien sûr le
service qu'il rentre à la justice et
notamment avec les revalorisations
adéquates
merci beaucoup monsieur Lefebvre vous
avez 17 secondes
je voulais remercier Monsieur le
Ministre pour ses précisions et rappeler
qu'un service public judiciaire clair
organisé performant et la garantie de la
solidarité de la solidité de notre État
de droit
merci la parole est à Monsieur Hussein
Bourgi pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lors des
audiences solennelles des tribunaux
judiciaires comme lors des conseils de
juridiction des cour d'appel de sujets
reviennent de manière récurrente le
premier concerne les moyens humains et
de nombreux chefs de cours regrettent
que les postes de magistrats qui leur
ont été alloués depuis la dernière loi
de finance nous soit toujours pas arrivé
cette situation ne tombe plus difficile
à comprendre que dans d'autres
juridictions des postes de juges sont en
surnombre comment et dans quel délai la
Chancellerie entend-elle remédier à
cette réalité
second point qui est soulevé lors de ces
réunions c'est celui qui concerne les
dysfonctionnements du logiciel Cassiopée
cela a été évoqué tout à l'heure par une
de nos collègues déployée depuis une
dizaine d'années à l'époque du ministre
Michel Mercier nous en sommes à une
cinquantaine de versions et il ne donne
toujours pas satisfaction monsieur le
ministre ce constat de temps plus
regrettable que l'on ne disposons pas de
référentiels d'activité pour évaluer les
besoins de chaque juridiction avec les
indicateurs et des éléments objectifs
dès lors l'attribution des moyens par la
Chancellerie ne se fait pas dans des
conditions tout à fait équitables
pouvez-vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre où en sont les travaux de la
chance à le riz pour nous doter d'outils
informatiques efficients et d'un
référentiel d'activité opérationnelle je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur Burgy le
référentiel nous devrions en disposer en
décembre
il faut longtemps pour créer un tel
référentiel
j'ai demandé moi il y a longtemps trop
longtemps sans doute que ce référentiel
soit mis en place il permet
effectivement c'est un très bel outil
pour le DJ décembre nous l'aurons il
sera à disposition bien sûr et vous
serez informés de cela alors je vais
essayer de vous répondre complètement
Cassiopée d'abord monsieur sénateur il
est exact des difficultés techniques ont
été soulevées à Paris à Versailles quant
à l'utilisation de Cassiopée cour
d'appel sont en cours d'analyse de
résolution et les solutions seront
probablement apportées premier semestre
Cassiopée tribunal est généralisée sur
tout le territoire
s'agissant des effectifs de magistrats
au sein de la cour d'appel de
Montpellier en juin dernier j'ai décidé
d'augmenter les effectifs de magistrats
dans cette cour de manière substantielle
c'est pas moins de quatre postes qui ont
été créés deux juges du siège de
magistrats au parquet et ces postes sont
à encore vacant on poursuit les efforts
de recrutement de magistrats 2023 verra
la plus grande promotion d'auditeurs de
justice de l'histoire de l'École
nationale de la magistrature avec 39
auditeurs ainsi et dès 2023 nous
réduirons évidemment la vacance de poste
voilà je le dis et c'est une réalité le
justice c'est plus de 20 ans d'abandon
budgétaire humain politique on peut pas
tout régler en un claquement de doigts
on s'y attache et les différents budgets
qui ont été obtenus plus de 40%
en ce qui me concerne 26% puisque vous
savez qu'en matière budgétaire trois
fois huit ça fait pas 24 mais 26 c'est
un effort considérable qui montre
l'intérêt que nous portons la justice de
ce pays merci Monsieur Bourgi vous avez
44 secondes
monsieur le ministre effectivement je
reconnais volontiers les efforts
budgétaires que vous évoquez nous nous
sommes en tous félicités à la commission
des lois et par contre la difficulté
vient du fait qu'elles ont du mal à se
traduire rapidement sur le terrain et
dans les juridictions et dans la cour
d'appel de Montpellier que vous avez
cité tout à l'heure qui est celle du
ressort où je suis élu je voulais vous
dire qu'effectivement des magistrats qui
n'arrivent pas à des postes de directeur
de greffe qui ne sont pas pourvus comme
c'est le cas actuellement au tribunal
judiciaire de Béziers ne facilite pas la
réduction des délais et de l'efficacité
de la justice et ce qui nous anime vous
et nous tous ici et sénatrice et
sénateurs si vous pouviez nous aider à
remédier à ces problèmes-là nous vous en
serions gré je vous remercie monsieur
ministre merci la parole est à Madame
Nadine le bélureau pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues le constat adressé par le
Comité des États généraux cela étudie et
particulièrement sévère sur l'état de
fonctionnement d'une institution qui ne
remplit plus ou très l'émission de
service public que les Français sont en
droit d'attendre la tonalité de ce
rapport se rapproche beaucoup d'ailleurs
de celui de 2017 de Philippe Bas 5 ans
pour sauver la justice mais cinq ans
plus tard nous en sommes toujours au
même point rares étant les
préconisations à avoir été mise en œuvre
au cours de la précédente législature de
constats du rapport bat d'ailleurs se
retrouve dans celui du comité en premier
lieu l'augmentation continue des
ressources allouées à la justice vous
vous en êtes récemment félicité mais
cette augmentation n'a toutefois pas
permis d'améliorer significativement son
fonctionnement et le service public
rendu aux justiciable en second lieu
l'institution judiciaire est confrontée
aux risques de rater la révolution
numérique les innovations technologiques
les plus récentes font émerger de
nouveaux acteurs privés qui peuvent
concurrencer l'institution judiciaire
appelant à une nécessaire régulation il
existe deux voies de réforme comme cela
a été dit la première concerne les
procédures en matière civile pénale
commerciale social nous en connaissons
la nécessité tout comme vous comme nous
connaissons également les contraintes
internes et conventionnelles la seconde
concerne le management de la justice
quelle organisation monsieur le ministre
du ministère envisagez-vous pour assurer
la bonne exécution des budgets votés la
fluidité de la gestion des ressources
humaines la maîtrise des frais de
justice la mise à niveau comme cela
vient d'être dit d'une informatique
judiciaire dont à chaque visite que nous
faisons dans les juridictions nous
sommes obligés de constater l'incroyable
inefficacité merci chers collègues merci
Monsieur le gardeesse
madame la sénatrice je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous et ça ne vous
étonnera pas nous avons embauché 700
magistrats 850 greffiers 2000 personnels
contre le juridiction mille auprès des
parquets
1000 aussi villes ils ont permis une
réduction des stocks de
28%. et vous trouvez que ça n'a rien
pardon mais c'est la moyenne nationale
il y a des juridictions aussi bien plus
encore 28% de mes chiens les chiffres à
votre disposition
28% en matière civile donc c'est une
justice naturellement qui déstocke et
c'est donc une justice qui va plus vite
vous dites que cela n'est rien c'est
votre analyse et je ne partage pas votre
votre sentiment maintenant maintenant
s'agissant de l'absence non mais
maintenant sur la question de la
sous-exécution budgétaire au niveau du
ministère alors sur les 15 dernières
années c'est en moyenne moins de 1% des
crédits votés en loi de finance initiale
qui n'ont pas été consommés soit environ
100 millions sur un budget de 9,6
milliards
c'est au fond assez faible et c'est 1%
n'a pas beaucoup marié sur une période
par exemple 1,9% en 2008 en 2008 je
0,4% en 2015 oui 1,8% en 2021 alors je
vous conseille d'effectivement une
hausse en 2020 2,6% on n'est plus en
2020 aujourd'hui en étant 2022 ça a été
imputable bien sûr la crise sanitaire je
ne doute pas que vous le savez avec un
pays à la répandant des moins et des
mois ce qui n'est pas permis au
ministère de dépenser leur crédit
normalement pas plus que ça a permis au
ministère de faire pousser les prisons
parce que je pense que dans un instant
j'entendrai cela j'ai déjà entendu vous
dites oui monsieur le sénateur bat je ne
lis pas dans vos pensées mais je vous
anticipe assez bien voilà alors voilà ce
que je voulais dire et
et
je vous ai à peu près répondu madame la
sénatrice pardon
des sous la parole est à Madame
Catherine belriti pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux les
conseils issus du rapport sauvé associés
une crise de l'autorité judiciaire et
une crise du service public de la
justice je voudrais insister sur le lien
étroit qui les unit en vous interrogeant
sur une cause commune qui ne devrait
pourtant pas être un problème les
variations démographiques en tant
qu'élude de Moselle je suis bien sûr
sensible au disparité de peuplement dans
les zones rurales mais je ne suis plus
encore à leur évolution lorsque nous
soutenons les politiques urbaines et la
croissance démographique de certaines
zones or j'ai pu le vérifier dans ma
région mais aussi lors d'un stage
d'immersion au tribunal de Bordeaux
l'accroissement de la population
urbaine particulièrement dans les
métropoles s'accompagnent naturellement
d'une augmentation des affaires pénales
et civiles c'est le cas récemment des
atteintes aux personnes mais aussi des
affaires familiales face à cette
dynamique démographique l'accroissement
d'une des judiciarisation de certains
contentieux où l'invention d'une énième
forte réforme pardon de la carte
judiciaire n'auront aucun effet limité
adapter la justice nécessite davantage
outre une augmentation généralisée des
moyens une meilleure anticipation et une
meilleure gestion dans l'emploi des
ressources humaines et matérielles de la
justice il pourrait s'agir de gestion de
carrière de mobilité géographique ou
d'instruments de suivi des masques
contentieuses entre autres exemples
quelle stratégie le ministre de la
Justice entendit l'adopter afin de
réussir cette anticipation des
évolutions démographiques et améliorer
la réponse de la justice dans ce
contexte
monsieur le garde des sceaux
quand vous voulez monsieur le garder son
[Rires]
les moyens humains des juridictions il
s'agisse des magistrats ou des greffiers
sont ajustés chaque année après examen
des données d'activité des juridictions
et l'outil dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui sera notre disposition dès
le mois de décembre nous permettra
évidemment permettra la DJ d'affiner les
besoins des différentes juridictions les
évolutions démographiques ont évidemment
un impact déterminant sur l'activité des
juridictions puisque une augmentation de
la population d'un ressort entraîne
inéluctablement nécessairement une
augmentation de l'activité des dite
juridictions et de même nous sommes
évidemment particulièrement attentifs au
profil socio-économique de la population
d'un ressort donné titre d'exemple on
aura tendance à favoriser la
localisation de poste de juge des
enfants dans les départements à la
population particulièrement jeune je
pense par exemple à Mayotte nous avons
localisé en 2022 un poste supplémentaire
de juge des enfants j'ajoute bien sûr
que les évolutions démographiques et
l'activité des juridictions ont
également une incidence sur l'évaluation
de la charge des magistrats il s'agit
d'un chantier qui est un chantier
important qui sera finalisé je l'ai dit
dans quelques jours mois de décembre et
on pourra ainsi localiser les postes de
magistrats au plus près des évolutions
d'activités des juridictions et donc au
plus près des évolutions démographiques
des territoires voilà la direction des
services judiciaires suit donc avec
attention ces évolutions démographiques
pour y répondre judiciairement au mieux
merci madame belretti vous avez 35
secondes merci pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre mais il faut
toutefois regretter que ces conseils et
ses propositions et déjà figuré en 20
dans les rapports sénatoriaux 2017 dont
celui du sénateur Philippe bat dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure et notamment
intitulé 5 ans pour sauver la justice
espérons qu'il puisse enfin être suivi
aujourd'hui merci merci la parole est à
Monsieur Gilbert Favereau pour le groupe
les républicains
monsieur le garde des sceaux le rapport
du Comité des états généraux de la
justice présidé par Monsieur sauvé
souligne la crise profonde de la justice
résultat de décennies de politique
défaillante ajoutant que seul une
augmentation substantielle des moyens
qui lui sont alloués permettra de
résoudre cette crise
le pré le projet de loi de finances
202023 prévoit effectivement une
augmentation de 8% du budget de la
justice qui serait porté à
9,57 milliards d'euros c'est un effort
notable mais il sans doute insuffisant
surtout quand le rapport sauvé
se montre également particulièrement
sévère avec les acteurs eux-mêmes de la
justice il considère qu'il faudra
clarifier leur rôle dans la société et
envisager une organisation globale de
l'institution il met en garde les
magistrats contre l'illusion de croire
que la justice seule peut préserver son
office et garantir son indépendance
il faut selon lui maintenir les rôles
respectifs du gouvernement et du
Parlement dans les grandes orientations
de la justice tout en associant plus
étroitement le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
mais à condition de questionner en même
temps le rôle et la composition de ce
même conseil supérieur de la
magistrature dans le souci de renforcer
la dépendance de la justice
au-delà des critiques faites au système
judiciaire le rapport sauvé souligne
mais nous le savons tous la
complexification et la multiplication du
droit et des procédures les délais de
jugement excessifs l'augmentation des
missions à signer à la justice et
surtout l'incompréhension des
justiciables alors que ce rapport
affirme la nécessité du réforme je vous
pose la question monsieur le garde des
sceaux à quand une grande réforme de
justice en France
elle arrive monsieur le sénateur elle
arrive
d'abord on a on a on a pris connaissance
des uns et les autres du rapport sauvé
puis des annexes tout ça a été transmis
le jour où le Président Sauvé a
transmission Rapport au Président de la
République ce jour-là les annexes le
rapport ont été adressé à tout le monde
bon j'ai reçu depuis les conférences
des chefs de juridiction des chefs de
cours le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature les forces de sécurité
intérieure j'ai reçu des citoyens qui
veulent d'ailleurs que la justice vous
avez raison aille plus vite et qu'elle
soit mieux connue d'où un passeport
éduque droit que je mets en place avec
Papon Ndiaye j'ai reçu les huissiers les
notaires les syndicats qui ont voulu
venir enfin tout le monde donc
maintenant on est dans une phase
d'arbitrage tout à l'heure madame la
sénatrice canaille m'a dit que il
fallait de temps en temps si j'ose dire
être un peu directif
concertation signifie pas molles les
arbitrages seront pris naturellement
vous y sera associé loi de programmation
début d'année prochaine et puis le
réglementaire va se mettre en place dans
les meilleurs délais parce que nous
sommes dans une forme d'urgence
il fallait réparer l'urgence avec les
moyens il faut embaucher ça c'est encore
les moyens et en l'occurrence les moyens
humains et il faut prendre des textes
qui permettent une simplification une
fluidité plus grande et donc une
rapidité une proximité et une protection
meilleure pour nos compatriotes donc
tout ça étant honte et nous aurons très
prochainement l'occasion de discuter de
tout ça vous donner le calendrier je
suis incapable précisément de le faire
mais la feuille de route c'est que le
plan d'action sera prêt pour l'automne
que naturellement il sera communiqué
discuté et que nous mettrons en oeuvre
ce que nous aurons dégagé de ces états
généraux voilà monsieur le sénateur
grosso modo ce que je puis vous dire le
jour près non la temporalité oui
l'automne nous serons prêts
la parole est à Madame Christine
bonfontidosa pour le groupe les
républicains merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'ai lu non sens
une certaine stupeur les préconisations
définitives du rapport sauvé relative au
cours d'appel le groupe de travail
renseigne à réfléchi à adapter les
ressorts des cours d'appel aux
populations en veillant à éviter qu'une
cour d'appel ne dépend de deux régions
judiciaires distinctes pourtant il
semble difficile de comprendre en quoi
le fonctionnement de la justice serait
améliorée en calcan la carte des
ressorts des cour d'appel sur la carte
des régions administratives sinon tout
au plus de façon extrêmement marginale
pour les parquets généraux le groupe de
travail résonne en termes de limite
administratives et non pas par rapport
au bassin de population ce même rapport
reconnaît qu'une telle réforme
souffrirait de plusieurs difficultés
sérieuses et pour l'inciter que
quelques-unes l'activité de 15
juridictions est impacté 8 juridictions
d'appels verrez leur activité réduite du
fait de la réduction de le ressort soit
plus de 25%. qu'il s'agisse du rapport
en simple pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées ou du rapport sauvé qui
n'exclut pas la fusion des cours d'appel
l'avenir de nombreuses cour d'appels
comme celle d'Agen semble menacer et
condamnés infinés à disparaître
avez-vous pour projet de retirer au
cours d'appel ne si jamais grandes
métropoles leur prérogatives de gestion
allez-vous retirer ces prérogatives à la
cour d'appel d'Agen au profit de celle
de Bordeaux
merci de me poser la question ça va me
permettre je l'espère une fois pour
toute de répondre à ces préoccupations
sur la suppression de tel ou tel cours
d'appel alors je vois fleurir des
initiatives à ces singulières et
récemment dans un théâtre des avocats se
sont réunis pour dénoncer une
suppression d'une cour d'appel qui
n'avait jamais été annoncée j'ai appelé
le bâtonnier je lui ai dit mais vas-y
curieux vous criez aïe avant de recevoir
un coup que personne ne veut vous porter
donc je vais vous rassurer il n'y a
aucune suppression de cours d'appel
c'est clair et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs je veux rappeler que j'ai
créé des tribunaux des audiences
foraines et j'irai ouvert des tribunaux
qui étaient fermés parce que je pensais
que la proximité ça doit et je pense
toujours que la proximité ça doit
raisonner dans les territoires et que à
Agen par exemple ben il y a un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui doivent
prendre la route pour se rendre à la
cour d'appel c'est compliqué et il
préférait par exemple l'audience foraine
de Villeneuve-sur-Lot et les exemples je
peux les multiplier voilà donc il est
pas question de supprimer des cours
d'appel il en a jamais été question
merci vraiment merci madame la sénatrice
de me poser cette question mais je suis
pas convaincu que ce soit la dernière
question de cette nature qu'on me qu'on
me pose parce que les fantasmes on se
sites singulier qu'ils reviennent de
façon récurrente
merci Madame bonfantido
mais simplement vous ne m'empêcherez pas
de craindre que si la Cour d'Appel
d'Agen devient secondaire elle ne soit
pas condamnée à fermer alors monsieur le
ministre je l'avoue je plais de coupable
coupable peut-être d'avoir raison trop
tôt merci
[Musique]
alors pourquoi conclure le débat la
parole est à Monsieur le Chester
Philippe Bas pour le groupe les
républicains et pour 5 minutes chers
collègues
vous n'aurez pas de droit de réponse
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
mes chers collègues
monsieur le garde des sceaux
se débat n'a pas été organisé pour
discuter de votre bilan il a été
organisé pour examiner ensemble les
perspectives ouvertes par les États
généraux de la justice c'est un débat
très intéressant je trouve et vous avez
eu à coeur de répondre généralement avec
précision à l'ensemble des questions qui
vous ont été posées bien entendu je ne
prétends pas en prenant la parole à
cette tribune chlore le débat il va
continuer entre nous parce que nous
avons beaucoup de travail à faire
ensemble et j'admets la manière dont
vous avez présenté les choses
gouvernement et Parlement sur la justice
comme ils le font sur la politique
étrangère ou sur la politique de défense
doivent trouver les voies
d'un peut-être pas d'un consensus mais
en tout cas d'une action commune de
redressement pour un grand service
public régalien que nous ne pouvons pas
laisser dans la situation
actuelle et puis je garde je sais à quel
point vous êtes sensible à ce qu'on
reconnaisse les efforts que vous faites
et je veux bien le faire mais si vous
voulez que nous puissions travailler
ensemble et que vous puissiez obtenir le
concours du Sénat il faut mettre les
problèmes sur la table c'est à dire pas
seulement montrer
les efforts qui sont faits mais aussi
montrer les difficultés qui résistent
aux redressement de la justice je vais
essayer de le faire très brièvement
parce que j'ai peu de temps
la transparence le réalisme sont les
gages d'un dialogue équilibré entre nous
il y a la question des moyens monsieur
le gardeesseau il est absolument exact
que depuis le gouvernement Castex et
sous votre impulsion les moyens de la
Justice ont fortement augmenté il est
également exact qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
recrutement de magistrats de greffiers
même si s'agissant des greffiers il y a
encore des vacances de postes assez
nombreuses tout ceci n'est pas discuté
entre nous mais il faut aussi prendre la
mesure y compris sur le plan budgétaire
et sur le plan des effectifs de
difficultés qui subsistent
sur le plan budgétaire n'oublions pas
tout de même que cette année est une
année à plus de 6% d'inflation quand
vous augmentez le budget de 8%, ça fait
pas 8% de pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaires et donc je ne veux pas
ainsi relativiser à l'excès
l'effort qui est fait mais il faut bien
voir que si c'était 8 % de progression
du pouvoir d'achat de la justice
évidemment l'effet de souffle serait
tout différent et il représente en
réalité à peu près un quart du chiffre
nominal de 8%, ça va être la même chose
pour le budget de l'année prochaine et
puis on voit bien qu'avec les problèmes
de la Défense nationale en pleine
ukrainienne les problèmes de l'éducation
nationale les problèmes de la santé la
bagarre et pour les budgets de chaque
grand service public est quand même très
difficile sachez que vous aurez notre
soutien pour le redressement de la
justice parce que pour le Sénat c'est un
engagement de longue haleine je dois
dire aussi que s'agissant de l'effort
financier vous répondez
exactement sur la consommation des
crédits de la justice mais ce faisant
vous oubliez de préciser que vous avez
un problème avec ce problème nous
voulons bien le faire notre c'est que
vous n'arrivez pas à dépenser vos
crédits d'investissement et en trois ans
c'est l'équivalent d'une année de crédit
d'investissement que vous n'avez pas pu
dépenser alors nous n'ignorons pas qu'il
y a eu le covid mais c'est pas la seule
difficulté parce que c'est avant que
vide qu'on avait déjà cette difficulté
là ça se traduit ensuite par la
difficulté que vous avez à réaliser le
programme des prisons ou alors là il y a
quand même je veux pas vous vous
associer à ce tour de passe-passe mais
enfin le président de la République en
2017 annonce 15000 places de prison et
disent finalement c'est sûr de mandat
heureusement qu'il en fait un deuxième
et il dit on en aura fait 7000 et puis
finalement vous faites le compte vous
n'en avez pas fait 7000 le nombre de
places net ouverte et de 2081 donc quel
travail mais je mesure aussi mettez les
difficultés sur la table on ne dit pas
que c'était réaliste de dire d'un
claquement de doigts je vais faire 15000
places mais il se trouve que c'est un
engagement présidentiel et par
conséquent il faut réaliser que nous
nous sommes pas donnés les moyens
d'atteindre ces résultats et que nous
avons un énorme problème parce que nos
prisons sont saturés et nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec la conclusion des
États généraux qui consiste à dire pour
incarcérer des condamnés on va désormais
libérer des détenus ça ça ne va pas et
donc nous avons besoin absolument de
travailler ensemble et de faire en sorte
que ces problèmes ne soient pas
escamotés mais mis sur la table pour que
nous puissions prendre des mesures plus
fortes que celles qui ont été prises
jusqu'à présent voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire je suis attaché aussi à la
stabilité des règles notamment en
matière pénale et pour autant il faut
simplifier le code de procédure pénale
nous avons de gros problèmes en ce
moment parce que la police judiciaire
est exemples elle a besoin d'être
encadré par le parquet mais les règles
sont tellement compliquées que nos
malheureux policiers ont du mal à mettre
en état des affaires qui permettent
ensuite au magistrats de condamner comme
il le voudrait voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup chers collègues merci
je vais suspendre la séance pour juste
quelques instants afin de permettre à
chacun de s'installer pour le prochain
point de ce jour donc la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]